The question, of course, is if this table here actually suggests that
randomized algorithms for 3-SAT will always be faster than deterministic algorithms.
And I would argue no here, simply for the reason that such a statement
would in some way have to be proven or at least argued for
with more than just empirical data, but I believe we can also think of some other reasons
why randomized algorithms currently have better upper bounds than deterministic ones.
So my question for you to think about is, what could be the reasons
that the randomized 3-SAT algorithms that we've just seen in the table
have generally better bounds than the deterministic ones?
Could it be because randomization is more powerful somehow than determinism?
Could the reason be that no one has yet had the right idea
simply how to design a better deterministic algorithm?
Or could it be that analyzing deterministic algorithms is in a way
more complex than analyzing randomized algorithms?